[Música]
hola bienvenidos a migrantes al programa
semanal de france 24 sobre el éxodo los
saluda juliet riaño
[Música]
las deportaciones de centroamericanos
desde eeuu aumentaron 1
451 por ciento durante los dos primeros
meses del 2022 respecto al mismo período
del año pasado fueron en total 14 mil
481 retornados según datos de la
organización internacional para las
migraciones en este programa nuestros
corresponsales en centroamérica nos
presentan dos historias de migrantes
devueltos a guatemala y honduras en el
caso de guatemala una vez repatriados
los migrantes deben acudir a
asociaciones humanitarias para pedir
ayuda porque los planes gubernamentales
son insuficientes
andrés suárez jaramillo y aurora by ut
prepararon el siguiente reporte
tres años después de haber sido
deportado de eeuu a guatemala douglas
murallas finalmente aceptó el duelo de
su retorno en eeuu este llega pues al
siguiente día pues prácticamente ya
tiene trabajo no como no como aquí de
que cuesta pues sí especialmente le digo
cuando uno tiene una cierta edad
a través de una ong con capital
extranjero
douglas a sus 52 años se inscribió en
esta capacitación para lograr un
documento clave la certificación laboral
que lo avale como técnico de
construcción en guatemala un oficio que
llevaba ejerciendo en eeuu por 30 años
antes de ser deportado
el mes que viene el 21 en guatemala
aterrizan a diario tres vuelos de
emigrantes repatriados desde estados
unidos y méjico aquí como pueden ver
este
acaban de bajar los retornados este es
el avión que trae a los que vienen de
los eeuu son decenas de miles cada año
los que llegan sin recursos al poner pie
en guatemala según afirman el gobierno
solo les ofrece un kit de higiene
distintas ong son las que están
brindando apoyo para reinsertarlos en
sectores productivos quisiéramos
ayudarle a todas pero es imposible
queramos dividirnos nosotros mismos
porque las personas que viene deportada
trae mucha necesidad
antes de ser deportado por segunda vez
douglas pasó 22 meses en una prisión
federal estadounidense por haber
reincidido como inmigrante ilegal
a su esposa e hijos se quedaron en eeuu
pero ya estuvo mañana otra vez a las 8
siempre lo he pensado de regresar pero
este por mis hijos verdad que están
pequeños todavía y ahorita tiene va a
cumplir 13 años el niño tiene 9 años
pero pienso en las consecuencias que
pueden haber la que me agarraran y
volver a una cárcel donde yo no quiero
estar otra vez ahora no se lo deseo a
nadie
y es mejor verlos en facetime que me
vayan ellos a ver a una cárcel valor por
ahora douglas vive con su madre del
gobierno no espera nada porque sabe que
los programas de ayuda son exclusivos
para los grupos familiares pero con el
certificado laboral en construcción
aspira a labrarse un futuro para
solventar su situación económica porque
de aquel sueño americano del que alguna
vez fue parte ya se despertó
e historias similares se cuentan en
honduras la deportación de hondureños
aumentó un 84 2% durante el primer
trimestre del año según informó el
observatorio consular y migratorio se
estima que al menos un millón de
hondureños han emigrado a eeuu escapando
de la pobreza y la violencia nuestra
corresponsal kenia torre se trasladó
hasta la frontera entre honduras y
guatemala a donde llegan autobuses
llenos de emigrantes la mayoría
procedentes de méjico el silencio de la
madrugada es interrumpido por el ruido
de estos autobuses en su interior hay
decenas de migrantes hondureños
deportados
denis martínez es uno de ellos
caminaba por mexico cuando lo detuvieron
y allí acabó su sueño de tener una vida
mejor en estados unidos
-me condiciones son unas conexiones muy
escasas que yo no tengo donde trabajar
yo busco mediciones de querer superarme
ayudar a mi familia
apenas pisaron honduras de anís y otros
emigrantes fueron trasladados al centro
de atención al migrante retornado
según el observatorio migratorio de
honduras en 2021 y principios del 2022
unos 40 mil hondureños fueron deportados
cuando intentaban cruzar hacia eeuu
en méxico
y me quitaron el dinero me quitaron el
teléfono me tiraron una mochila de ropa
en un canal de agua yo lo quiero recoger
y yo le doy gracias a dios que así como
me llevo así me trabajo las autoridades
del refugio comentan que desde su
creación el flujo de hondureños
deportados es constante
en meses altos recibimos cerca de 300
personas al día cuando cuando tenemos un
flujo alto y si ustedes vieron el
ingreso de los buses recibimos cerca de
200 personas en este momento
la presidenta de honduras xiomara castró
ha anunciado que su gobierno trabajará
en una estrategia para reducir el flujo
migratorio de hondureños hacia eeuu
mientras tanto denis volverá al
encuentro con su familia y enfrentarse
con el desempleo y la pobreza
y las deportaciones tienen graves
consecuencias para quienes son obligados
a regresar a un país del que salieron
para algunos retornan a una nación que
ni siquiera conocen por el tiempo que
permanecieron fuera para otros significa
volver a entornos inseguros y en el
medio muchas familias resultan separadas
hasta que inmigrantes de france24 los
invitamos a comentar en nuestras redes
sociales con el hashtag migrantes f24
sigan con más información en france 24 y
france 24 puntocom
[Música]